Що таке Шенгенська угода?
Велика мрія європейців - подорожувати Європою
без перевірок на кордоні, наче це одна велика держава
- стала реальністю завдяки Шенгенській угоді…
…названій на честь невеликого містечка в Люксембурзі,
де цю угоду, власне, підписали у 1985 році.
Нині до Шенгенської зони належать 26 країн ЄС,
а також Ісландія, Норвегія, Швейцарія та Ліхтенштейн.
Громадяни країн-не членів ЄС також користуються перевагами Шенгена.
Отримавши шенгенську візу, вони можуть вільно
пересуватися практично по цілій Європі.
Криза біженців у Європі поставила угоду під удар.
Багато новоприбулих не мають документів,
що посвідчували б їхню особу.
Тому їхні дані часто неможливо перевірити.
Як наслідок деякі країни тимчасово відновили
прикордонний контроль, із міркувань національної безпеки.
Це погана новина для європейської торгівлі, яка
залежить від безперешкодного руху товарів.
Без нього неможливе виробництво під замовлення.
Візьмемо, до прикладу, Volkswagen.
Двигуни виготовляють в Угорщині та постачають у чітко визначені строки.
Завдяки цьому немає потреби в дорогому зберіганні товарів на складах.
Контроль та затримки на кордоні покладуть
цьому край і продукція здорожчає.
Якщо країни Європи знову закриють свої кордони,
може постати й питання про доцільність
єдиної європейської валюти.
Відновлення кордонів усередині Європи
означатиме кінець Шенгенської зони.